journée bien comme il faut et on va
petit à petit avancer vers notre
tournant alors je suis en train de tout
bien mettre en place comme il faut
vérifier combien va bien ça lui a marre
khune premier et on va enlever facebook
commençait bien et j'étais en train de
lire il a oublié de faire un petit truc
vous donner le lien du tournoi comme ça
ça c'est fait ça c'est fait c'est la
bonne news bon et maintenant la petite
chose que j'ai à faire
salut loach est ce salut antonymes ce
soir à 19 heures du coup il y aura le
tournoi d'abu dhabi je sais pas si vous
êtes au courant
l'abu dhabi masters il n'ya pas l'intro
à fo ça dépend les chaînes anthony main
c'est par ma chaîne perso du coup du
coup malheureusement non là on va avoir
une nouvelle musique alors
salut article finkle on peut il partir
de ce soir et je crois pas un je crois
pas que vous puissiez les gars
malheureusement malheureusement je pense
pas que vous puissiez en train de
rentrer du monde aujourd'hui on va
laisser le crédit à ousse ça change un
peu
on va essayer tous les tester on refera
un king of the hill demain et vendredi
ce sera fab
du coup un fable imagine qui fera 1 960
parce qu'il aime bien je lui ai laissé
son jeu préféré
je me suis dit que ça lui ferait plaisir
salut soumis du cuir bonjour à toi
le truc c'est qu'on va tous les essayer
je sais que fable il aime bien 1960
donc je préfère aller c'est affable 960
et moi faire les trucs qui l'est moins
quoi au moins il sera heureux
salut la capote masqué et chrétiens ou
si tu manges une pièce et tu peux la
réutiliser du coup c'est marrant comme
je moi c'est dans les variantes
enfin à part le king of the hill en fait
qui avait paru pas le mal c'est celle
que j'ai fait 1 960 j'aime bien on va
dire trois échecs j'ai pas trop aimé
beat saccades j'aime moins aussi on va
dire que le crédit house celui sur
lequel j'ai le plus joué en fait j'ai
plus qu'il fait après ce fait plus d'un
an et demi que j'ai pas joué donc je me
rappelle plus vraiment comment ça se
fait mais je me rappelle que ça c'est un
jeu qui m'amusait qui m'amusait bien
après le succès que le king of the hill
il ressemble vraiment aux vrais échecs
on va dire que dans les jeux qui
ressemble pas du tout aux échecs c'est
celui que je préfère ce que qui perd
gagne j'aime pas les échecs où tu joues
un coup de coude trois coups 4 ou 5 ou
j'aime pas
plus les échecs tu joues de quoi à la
fois donc plus ça me saoule message
amiens donc aujourd'hui à l'aréna et en
crédits house donc je mets le lien
elle commence dans douze minutes
on n'est pas très nombreux pour le
moment n'est que 5
est-ce qu'on va battre notre record
notre anti record de participation je
sais que tu es variant de c'est plus dur
pour motiver les gens à jouer mais ma
foi pourquoi pas on essaye un peu quoi
ça lui fait signe au 12 mai ça rentre
petit à petit salé petit à petit rentrer
dans l'arène
je suis pas sûr d'y arriver aurais tu
sais que tu vas bien réussir à jouer en
numérique sous y salue de chasse frites
saluer 1068 170 donc le principe si tu
manges une pièce tu peux la réutiliser
salut marcoux ne t'y es premiers salue
ton ton salut à toi présent paillard les
beats ouais mais en fait le mardi du
coup je ferai deux trois rondes de title
tous des objectifs de 1800 enfin la
journée try hard mardi soir tapas
quelques conseils pour cette vague faut
ça va venir avec l'expérience gars et il
ya des gens qui sont le chat
twitch bitstream genre dire aussi salut
salut abdel hamid je vais mettre le lien
sur les deux côtés au moins les gens
peuvent participer
je mange une d'alger une dame en plus si
je veux exactement antonymes when the
bug sur le poteau de makoun et un
premier et merci au revoir et merci
chasse fritz qui est content du de
l'événement caritatif écoute c'était la
moindre des choses
jeudi je passerai sur un autre stream
caritatif j'ai pas le lien de la chaîne
je vous donnerai c'est demain jeudi si
je dirai demain je passerai sur le
stream d'un joueur de poker pour jouer
une petite heure avec la commune donc je
passerai je passerai sur un autre stream
du coup pour la bonne cause
pour un petit peu aux échecs et oui
antonymes c'est valable pour tous un
adversaire aussi bien en bien entendu on
peut rejoindre l'aréna quand on veut
exactement ong et salue b baup au barça
il ya vraiment des pros différend entre
le soir sur vitry mais le jour la
journée sur surface comme je passe la
vue d'ailleurs la rediff de l'interview
de 2ème but el haya le chien-loup quoi
j'adore le chien loup c'est un trésor
cool chez ba ça il me plaît ce pseudo
alors ça lui accorda d'un ami non
vraiment l'interview de la nouvelle aile
et hop tu comptes en fait je suis fier
de mon interview faite je trouve que
j'ai été très bien je les réécoute et je
me suis trouvé excellent la nature à des
phrases je me trouve nul autant là je me
suis trouvé excellent parce que c'est
pas un truc les interviews c'est pas
quelque chose sur lequel je suis
vraiment au point normalement c'est pas
du tout ma spécialité dans le dans le
stream game mais je trouve que je m'en
suis pas mal tiré honnêtement non je
trouvais que c'était qualitatif dans le
sens où je trouve que c'était bien
c'était bien dosé ouais les beats à 4
aussi des noces on essaiera d'en faire
quand il y aura un tournoi de beach à
quatre avec papier plus con c'est bien
mais qu'ils pensaient que j'avais fait
des études de joanne kelly si tu te
souviens de taef à cul comme quoi ouais
non pas du tout on sentais que j'avais
préparé ouais bah je l'avais lavage et
du gd toujours devant moi mais j'avais
j'avais les questions les questions
étaient là vous elle nous fait que des
questions donc à quoi elles étaient
préparées l'interview quand même
saluant chantier de faire votre plein
d'essence webb a peut-être à blaye
étaient aussi contents de l'interview en
mode p pouze avec des questions sympa
mais c'était sur le carnet de la doit
s'intégrer volé dans la marge
ouais j'ai écrit comme une j'écris très
mal je suis à je suis très mauvais à
l'écrit je suis très mauvais à l'écrit
j'écris assez mal vraiment je veux dire
par là je parle pas de l'écriture d'un
point de vue typographique ma mon
écriture est déjà dégueulasse mais je
veux dire par là que je j'écris très mal
le but du prêt diarra ou c'est de faire
échec et mat la seule différence avec
les échecs c'est quand tu manges une
pièce elle peut revenir en vie de ton
côté non j'écris je je je construis très
mal mais phrase je suis nul en grammaire
je suis vraiment très très mauvais mais
vraiment c'est mon niveau est
incroyablement mauvais c'est étrange
d'ailleurs parce qu'à l'oral je me
débrouille plutôt pas mal
et j'apprends j'ai appris plusieurs
langues enfin je parle le russe
couramment et quand je parlais beaucoup
anglais je parlais pas si mal anglais
que ça avec un accent un petit peu fort
mais pour un français on va dire que ça
va mais écrire pour moi ça a toujours
été compliqué vraiment compliqué je ne
sais pas c'est que c'est quelque chose
qui m'est difficile de faire après vlad
m'a dit oui c'est parce que tu ne t'es
jamais me medici kuti mais pendant deux
ans et que tu fais ça six heures par
jour tu vas avoir un excellent niveau me
dis c'est que de la logique très simple
la décrit très bien d'ailleurs
panard naturel we know fait quoi être un
peu un petit instit ceux qui écrivent le
plus mal ce le plus à l'aise à l'oral
est maintenant de l'allemagne il faut
que tu écris il faudrait que tu écris
veut dit il faut que tu prennes deux
trois auteurs qui te plaisent que tu
copies leur manière d'écrire du coup tu
pourras que les copier après puis dans
un deuxième temps tu pourra créer ton
propre style mais il sait très simple
mais dit quand tu es mauvais juste eu
copie quelqu'un mais qui prend 2,3
décrivent un thème bien c'est d'écrire
dans leur style la première année et
après la deuxième année tu crées ton
propre style les blattes a fait des
études de journalistes pour la peine oui
naturelle naturelle où il vient
surnaturel donc c'est son conseil est ce
que les parties en question sont évalués
à elle sous évaluée pour le classement
crédit house lecourbe non mais c'est
intéressant fait il utilisera donc pour
apprendre à écrire il a utilisé
exactement la même technique aux échecs
c'est genre tu apprends les ouvertures
tu copies un joueur et après dans un
deuxième temps tu crées ton propre style
mais vannes ne publie pas en réalité il
écrit des nouvelles mais ne les publient
pas il ya très peu de gens qui ont eu la
chance de lire ses nouvelles et la
copier des auteurs russes cv castaing je
sais plus les cales honnêtement mais
maintenant il écrit dans son propre
style mais ils ne publient pas je ne
publierai pas tant que ce ne sera pas au
niveau de dostoïevski tolstoï
c'est qui peut se permettre à décrire
moins bien je ne publierai pas ça le
niveau est trop bas
je ne saurais que dans le top 10 des
meilleurs auteurs russes ça ne suffit
pas mais ils écrivent un vent bien sans
rigoler
comment peux-tu comprendre si j'écris
bien ou pas mais un nom parmi les pubs
havre avant parce qu'ils trouvent que
son niveau est trop faible
mais juste comme avant c'est trop
perfectionniste il pense que quand vos
échecs qui pense que jouer en dessous
2006 ça représente aucun intérêt de
jouer aux échecs juste tu vois trop
perfectionniste malade c'est ça un
auteur à deux mille cinq cents lots il
ne bouge c'est à peine écrire un mot il
s'est à peine décidée une lettre donc ça
c'est ça ouais mais son conseil est
assez bon jeu je pense je j'ai
l'impression que le conseil était pas
mauvais de beaucoup lire quelques
auteurs et d'essayer de choper leur
style j'ai trouvé ça intéressant comme
conseil tu sais que l'art et aux
échéanciers comme ça à l'époque et les
échecs en réalité aussi à l'aréna
commencé à quelle heure à 13h40 et ce
mot n'appartient pas à cette phrase
cette figure de s'il n'appartient pas à
cette phrase on n'a pas une notification
aujourd'hui on dirait ça arrive un les
bugs motifs mais donc si un jour je me
mettais à écrire et c'est ce que je
ferai d'ailleurs ça me robin qui il est
qui fait les articles pour tu as comme
en français je trouve qu'il écrit très
très bien il écrit vraiment très bien
moi j'aime bien camus en fait donc
j'aurai peut-être relu camus à fond
j'aurais peut-être lucas mieux à fond ou
muka en verlan la paix c'est d'actualité
ouais moi j'ai bien aimé l'étranger moi
j'aimais bien camus et les boris vian
mais bon c'est un peu un hostile boris
vian l'étranger perturbant moi j'ai vécu
longtemps à l'étranger pas mais camille
j'étais fan
après boris vian je sais qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui aiment pas trop
mais où l écume des jours j'irai cracher
sur vos tombes l'herbe rouge 3 excellent
bouquin
mais à
mais vos régions ce que j'aimais bien
c'est que ça ressemble un peu à mesrine
quelque part il peut se passer un peu
tout et n'importe quoi c'est assez
inattendu le j'ai l'impression que le
livre peut changer de direction assez
vite c'est très décousue et voilà ouais
céline voyage au bout de la nuit aussi
j'ai beaucoup aimé mais après parfois
que j'ai dit que j'avais bien aimé
céline voyage au bout de la nuit'
impression que tu vas te faire insulter
par les gens dans le chat donc je fais
je fais plus attention alors que mon sa
manière d'écrire extraordinaire un bon
alors à temps
j'essaie de claquer un à ce jeu font
claquer du matos faut attaquer le roi
claquer du matos ouais c'est vrai céline
c'est un terrain glissant lors que c'est
un bon auteur c'est dommage parce que on
parle bien évidemment de l'auteur et pas
forcément de ses idées sont son écriture
moi me me paraît vraiment excellente
après c'est eiffage je trouve ça
vraiment bizarre de
enfin voilà donc je fais gaffe
donc alors là j'ai envie de claquer en
rêve cette et d'envoyer des échecs
parce que j'ai du matos je vais
maintenant cavalier là mais ce que j'en
ai assez de matos ce qui va échanger
faut que je réussisse a agressé son roi
non ils échangent pas je suis peut-être
un peu nigel les rockets pour le moment
j'ai affaibli sont rois mais peut-être
que j'ai trop sacrifié je m'en veux te
lent qu'un peu de pièces en fait
c'est pas comme au blitz à quatre mois
je me suis un peu un peu emballé là il a
bien joué avec son chang'e 2
je me retrouvais vit très mal je mette
un pion là ou là j'ai oubliés cave a
lieu demain je vais abandonner cette
partie ratée faut que je me remette en
mode crise yahoo c'est que j'arrête de
penser envie de ça 4
les deux jeux sont différents faut que
je me je me réajustons couilles ainsi à
des pièces qui a qui arrivent sur
l'échiquier c'est parce qu'on peut on
peut les réutiliser
ça c'est pas une bonne ouverture seconde
c'était cavaliers ainsi cédé 5 le truc
qu'il fallait jouer ça c'est pas mal en
crise house donc là on fait pareil ont
déjà un pion je le pose comme j'ai mangé
un pion au début je peux le poser est
lui aussi là un pion vous voyez tu as
des restrictions sur les drops non non
il n'y a pas de restriction alors la
foux princesse et un coup candidat parce
que lui il va pouvoir peut-être
m'attaquer georges et peut-être intérêt
à faire 6 pour un peu couvrir pas
fondées 4 que si je récupère le car il
se posera un cavalier en g2 sur échec ça
ça va être intéressant pour moi ok
alors
tout est allé vite rockets il faut que
j'essaie d'attaquer son roi je vais
remettre le fou angers catch attack lui
quand même
et il se remet l'inde jamais une tour en
des huit c'est bien blindé quoi elle
prend lui et je prends lui j'ai un lion
de plus un vrai jeu peut-être poser lyon
page deux pions regardez ce que je vais
faire je posais un pion h 2 comme ça je
n'attaque la tourelle bouger je vais
poser un pion g2 après c'est ça la
difficulté à ce jeu c'est que là tout
d'un coup on fait ce qui fait des trous
là bas mais ça me permet de lui être les
deux pions dans la gueule mais là il est
fou tout foutu au foot your way du coup
ça ça a clairement savaient clairement
posé problème les trous qu'il avait de
l'autre côté dans ce jeu est bizarre
hein
je me rappelle que j'avais pas mal joué
sur une chaise comme prévu les tournois
y avait un truc avec des prix et je
m'étais améliorée et commence à faire
des parties pas si mauvaise les pièces
là bas ça j'attaque ça et je prends
toujours important de gagner un pion
deux pions ouais donc là je fais tout
tomber il a plein de trous il ya la dame
attaquer et dim pioncer 7
ça fait tout de suite mal lappion des
six échecs ça fait encore mal
alors maintenant faut pas laisser
repartir le roi je vais sortir le fou
est là le roi en fait il faut tout
sacrifier pour le faire monter on va le
mat et là je vais mettre un échec avec
la dame a un bon jeu faire participer
cette dame au jeu d'accord alors il se
défend encore plus ou moins je mette un
fou ici et la dame en f 7 essart a maté
faut pas les laisser pauser pièces pour
intervenir à les flottilles fr on va
essayer d'un petit peut enchaîner les
victoires
donc c'est vraiment un mode de jeu sympa
c'est vraiment un mode de jeu sympa ok
là ça on a envie de faire ça et
peut-être le rock pour le moment au
moins j'ai un peu sorti son roi d'accord
pourquoi pas
c'est peut-être bien joué mon jeu fer
qui les prend au 5e - je reprends un
pion je vais prendre le fou mais j'ai
quand même avoir déjà deux pions le lave
le fasse vraiment grave d'avoir un roi
sortie puisque ça permet de poser sur
échec et cetera
et là vous voyez lui peut poser plus
qu'un cavalier et moi j'ai pas mal de
choses dans mes mains et je vais pouvoir
lui faire mal alors je peux soit mettre
un pion f5
je peux aussi le mettre en échec mais
j'arrive sans que je mette un pion f5
pour récupérer le cavalier ça me
redonnera un cavalier pour attaquer ça
ne peut être qu agréable si prompts du
pion je prends le cavalier voilà et
maintenant j'ai deux cavaliers imposer
un fou et il n'a pas d' attaque donc là
maintenant on va faire mal on va poser
cavale on va poser lyon
on peut toujours pas mater on va prendre
une fois comme ça va pouvoir poser tour
donc là quand il reprend la dame c'est
un pion un parce que c anciennement un
pion et donc on va pouvoir poser tour et
après cavaliers j'ai vite on posera
cavale sur matt m'a laissé gagner mon
quoi une fois que le roi est sorti c'est
du rhin mais assez marrant comme je
pense que tu peux faire des belles
attaques de maths en vrai je préfère
largement sa au blitz à 4 c'est beaucoup
plus amusant je vais faire un peu le
même truc je vais monter un maximum ma
position pour prendre de l'espace dont
ils échangent tout de suite tu veux me
faire quelque chose avec son cavalier
peut-être c'est dommage que tu voies au
lieu d title tuesday juste pour vous
pour vous dire un truc tu as comme on
parlait des titles puces dès hier est-ce
qu'on préférerait pas avoir finalement
toutes les semaines un event comme ça un
peu marrant avec des tours de qualifs
comme ils en ont eues fait plutôt que de
se taper le title tuesday ou de toute
façon on va avait bien compris bryceland
danger puisqu'il a cassé cette un peu
mal
j'ai plus de choses à poser que lui vous
m'avez bien compris ce serait pas juste
1000 fois mieux
bon alors là en vrai il peut pas
vraiment prendre je rock au moins j'ai
mon roi l'abri parce que je vais poser
alors maintenant un truc qui peut être
intéressant c'est aussi suspensif et
puis on prend et du foin qu'il ya un fou
en bref cette annonce je fais peut-être
même fou g6 comme ça je garde mon fou en
réserve dans la main et j'y encaisse son
foie et fuite serait donc là je lui fais
fondamentalement très mal
tu peux en paraître lascaux gros tu sais
s'ils s'y prenaient toutes les idées que
je leur donne on n'en serait pas là
ok on va poser le cas valence 5 c'est
une bonne caisse pour contrôler si le
roi monte on mettra la dame la cie
droits des sans mettra le lion rang f7
et on ira prendre le cavalant g8 et donc
lascars en train de bien se passer
j'ai envie de mettre le cavalier en
aussi ce contrôle quand même pas mal de
cases mais il n'y a pas de macapa de fou
17 je vois pas de maths à
rien mat il est parti du mauvais côté a
qualifié le droit à bordel dumas large
et dole qui fait un gros tournoi aussi à
lies fines ce qu'en dit alors et lui
laisser la dame venir au centre et on va
l'agressé par la suite d'accords avec le
cavalier 3,6 prends je prends il prend
je prends dont il fait pas alors je vais
prendre une fois je vais le mettre en
échec
j'ai envie qu'il fasse ses six dans ce
mode de jeu parce que ça me permettra un
jour de pause et influencé cette ça
j'imagine que vous l'avez compris
par contre ils m'attaquent bien droit
et on était en difficulté parce que si
je rock j'aime pas trop j'ai posé je
pose un fonds a je crois même si j'aime
pas trop eu à faire échec je vais mettre
le fou ici il n'ya pas reposé un quart
ayant f4 c'est peut-être un poil
dangereux
ce qui l'a beaucoup de pièces à poser le
cavaliere f4 va me faire très mal
on s'en suit peut prendre h3 prendrait
fera que j'ai le temps de me
reconstruire un château pions g4 g13
prendre une fois les pauses un hayon pis
si je poserai un deuxième million pie xi
et du coup je serai blindés alors le
problème c'est qu'il a un gros avantage
matériel
il a deux pièces de plus failli la
gagnante s de plusieurs coups mais je
pourrais mettre un pion h3 et je bloque
complètement toute velléité sur moi et
ça c'est bien je me suis bien protégé le
roi ouais je vais me faire la tortue
direct et je vais rocha après comme ça
il va avoir beaucoup de mal à venir me
chercher
là il peut plus il peut plus approcher
de mouroir
il peut rien imposer proche de lui j'ai
complètement tout bloquer et maintenant
on va attaquer de l'autre qu'on va
attaquer on va l'attaquer
ça c'est pas mal an crécy house quand
vous réussissez à faire ça
ouais c'est un peu plus autres mais on a
besoin d'être pleutre à ce jeu c'est un
jeu où tu dois être l'autre ont valu
échanger lecavalier
bon on lui fait mal et je lui met le
cavalier ans et 7 est maintenant le
petit affaiblissement c6 qui paye côté
français et maintenant je prends la tour
ok c'est pas forcément encore l'amérique
je vais faire flouer f4 mais là je là ça
va là j'ai peut-être de la tour a posé
il ne peut absolument pas posé proche de
mon roi bah je suis content quoi lâcher
heureux et je vais pouvoir tout lui
poser sur la gueule là il est mal mais
voyez c'est hyper important de bloquer
reste donc l'âge échanges
ok maintenant si je fais cavale et ses
huit il va partir en rêve 6 avec le roi
je vais faire dame des huit échecs
ouais je vais aller le prendre à
rebrousse-poil un truc qui est chiant
c'est que mes cavale sont loin mais son
roi va être obligé de monter ok je vais
faire un échec du coup si posant le set
je prends et je vais prendre la tour
pour que je fasse très attention de pas
me faire contre attaquer quand même mais
bon truc c'est qu'il manque un cavale
pour mener les attaques
donc il pose un fou je vais le prendre
et je vais aller prendre là bas mais son
roi et bien oui il peut il peut mettre
un cavalier en f3 mais je prends deux
foires est pour le moins il peut pas
s'approcher j'ai des tours
les tours sont pas forcément plus forte
que les cavaliers les fous à ce jeu gta
et ses sept quarts aile ie8 comme idée
pour venir le déterrer cic7 ça va faire
mal parce que je veux venir ensuite je
le prend à rebrousse poil
je met le cavalier 1,8 et je vais lui
mettre la 2 x h quatre tours fkt jeu le
match
c'est chaud mais j'ai réussi à le
réussir à le faire sortir de son trou et
vous voyez un peu j'ai construit mon
petit chapiteau là j'ai construit mon
petit château ouais non mais c'est un
jeu intéressant
alors je me développe et ça c'est pas
grave parce que je remettrai des pions
proche de - face à peut être chiant cani
pas attaquer la dernière et une
ouverture sur quatre cavaliers avec 6,5
des cinq puis on prend on prend et après
se développer normal je crois par notre
éloize ce joyau avait complètement je
suis pas très fort à juan - personnes ok
un truc qui peut être intéressant je
pensais tout est changé parce que du
coup je vais pouvoir rentrer en b2c se
fait pions transmettrait le fou en b 2-1
- j'attaque la tour j'attaque le pion et
cif et dames b5 j'échange les dames et
je remets un pion bon alors ça c'est pas
grave je vais quand même aller pour les
changes des dames parce que c'est lui
qui a le droit le plus ouvert et je vais
essayer de le mater à la va vite
ok bon j'ai quand même prendre la tour
et là j'ai des choses à poser un l'ag du
matos une dame seule peut pas me faire
mal tout de même pas vraiment mettre en
échec je peux poser les lions pour me
protéger
et moi je vais peut-être mètres la tour
en b1 déjà histoire de lui parler
poliment mais donc ça je prends c'est
par un souci donc alors il ya une petite
attaque mais honnêtement je devrais
mater là quand même
je passe derrière
ok
je vais remettre un échec avoir fait
leur mettre en échec là je commence qu'à
marc beaucoup de pièces sur son roi il
va te veut soit il vient par là mais je
fais maths non ouais ok je vais bien
déterrée
j'ai aspiré et mater ce qui existe s'est
fait détruire ouais je t'ai fait
détruire alors f3 saint-germain genre de
quoi proscrire à ce jeu parce que ça
fait d'être ou genre la cac et prend 2,4
et puis on rêve de ceux déjà une menace
ça c'est vraiment à proscrire
parce que du coup
ouais bah je vais faire un mécha été tué
le matin f21 ça c'est à proscrire les
cougars f3 d'ailleurs samaté très vite à
les marques ou des premiers mais je vais
vraiment fun 1 alors il m'empêche
d'aller jouer la balle et je lui met le
pion aux quatre comme ça je me place un
peu je le repousse et je le repousse à
et je mette la dame ici bon il va
sûrement faire roi et femmes et au moins
gelé dayraut kg un peu bloqué le truc
là-bas fouet fin
donc est pas idiot je vais faire ça je
mettrai le fond 17 en défense et grand
roque je vais repartir par là bas le
trail fois en 17 pour bien couvrir comme
il faut prendre une fois hélas deux
pions maintenant il va avoir deux pions
en main ok je suis content qu'ils
mettent le pion là dans le sens où ge
ce lion pas ok mais ses pions partout
mais auquel j'ai changé je les obtiens
des cas ok c'est cool si fait cavalier
f3 je pense prendre ici et prendre ici
ouais je vais défiler la dame
tant pis c'est pas si fort une dame et
je vais rockets ce que je vais quand
même désorganiser les pions qu'elle je
vais prendre l'a déjà je met le fond b2
comme ça je le récupère et je veux
récupérer des pions pour les poser et la
dame ma foi ce pas si grave je vais
prendre l'aps qui peut pas reprendre
mais il peut pas reprendre ce que j'ai
échec
enfin il pouvait reprendre mais je veux
dire par là que la du coup ok alors
maintenant je réussisse à attaquer à
percer et je mette une toux en b2 il va
faire cavaler ses deux jumelles le x 4
ouais je vais essayer mettre le foin 4
ok on va essayer d'échanger échanger on
pourra poser plus plus tard je récupère
un claval ok si je prends ces deux il
prend avec le roi je prends de cavale
j'arrive toujours pas à lui mettre des
chèques
ok alors il faut réussir à percer la
muraille
j'arrive à le mettre en échec
faut que je perce intelligemment là je
vais être le front g6 je t'ai d'essayer
de claquer en d3 pourquoi remettre un
pion et met une dame
question je vais prendre une fois là je
vais prendre une fois là
si prend du cac et je voulais faire
échec mais là je vais pouvoir poser la
dame sur échec en d2 comme ça je prends
je pose sur échec en d2 et là je fais
mal roye b 1
je pose en selle sur échec du coup je
vais pouvoir poser en g pouvoir faire c1
dames et gagner donc en fait toute
l'idée c'était de trouver une manière de
de faire de pause et la dame en d2 moi
je vais exprimer les petits jeunes
samedi peuvent ils écrit sur mon twitter
à les barbarians barban qui joue bien
qui va être un adversaire forcément
difficile dans ce format pas raciste je
comprends pas vraiment l'idée qu'il se
fait des trous ok je vais rockets et moi
je vois un trou j'y rentre
mc c'est de faire ça
ok il ya beaucoup de trous je vais
monter ça comme ça ouais alors si je
pousse le pion d66 fait qui prend des
cations français cette épreuve trois
pions pro f3 et je vais pas réussir à
mater malheureusement mois qu'ils ont
affaire d'âme ici
piron l'indre a par contre fait qu'ils
avaient quatre maintenant ok là je vais
faire des six par contre et ci prend je
prends là quand même je pense ça doit
aller
et sinon je vais prendre et prendre mon
espace si grave parce que son pion g4
efforts pour lui c'est peut-être pas si
grave encore qui est par contre ça ça
m'a l'air d'être un poil too much et
j'ai pensé qu'ils joueraient ça mais ça
me paraît un poil too much
ok alors il va gagner du matos assez
clair ok tu mettes la dame en g3 pour le
moment pour jeter un oeil là-dessus je
vais essayer de faire roi la epyon g2
pour éviter de me prendre des échecs
bon d'un autre côté il à tous les
cavaliers de l'expliquer il peut plus
trop faire de choses méchantes avec et
mon roi est un peu plein des dons
continuent à poser à fond je mette la
dame en h4
il faut vraiment que je mette un pied en
g2 rapidos l'idée c'est qu'est ce qui
pousse le cavalier je fais d'amd 8,1
merde ça j'avais oublié
là je suis dans le dur parce que je
pouvais pas prendre une pause et
cavaliers sur échec du coup il a
beaucoup de pièces du coup il a beaucoup
trop de pièces le faire j'ai 3
c'est relou là j'ai pris la dame mais
mais là c'est pas facile
il a trop de hockey il prend ça je
prends ça il va remettre le cas vaillant
h cinq ans d'écart à toi c'est chiant
mile island
il a tellement de matos je faire x 3 que
je sue à grosses gouttes
bon alors attendez cavaliers f3 et
j'avais pas vu là je me fais défoncer
je le fais juste défoncer la haye est
bon ça c'est bien joué et il va mater a
il a bien joué je me suis fait avoir
dommage dommage il a fait une bonne
partie j'ai pris cette dame je pensais
que ce serait bon et puis finalement
c'était pas terrible on va remonter dur
ce jeu où la gelée allant des 5
je suis allée un poil loin ouais non du
rila il a fait une bonne partie
c'est pas un jeu facile du tout c'est
que la dame c'est un truc que je suis
restée mme souvent alors ok ça ça doit
pas être le top parce que je vais lui
prendre ça il prend la dame c'est la
même erreur un peu que moi dans la
partie précédente
allez je vais prendre ici ok alors
maintenant comment faire
comment faire comment faire comment
faire alors je vais faire fouache quatre
échecs
je vais mettre la tour en g2 et je vais
essayer de faire f 2 et prendre comme ça
j'ai deux menaces bon ça là je vais la
gagne j'ai lol avec caracole en tête du
tournoi est un gars qui a neuf points de
plus que moi
il reste 25 minutes allez on se bat les
mecs je sais pas si vous vous qui fait
alors dans le chat ou pas la f2 sari
sport puisque orange et reprendre sur
échec quoi qu'il en soit et ce jeu même
reprendre sur matt ait eu rupture du 505
ouais c'est marrant je te faire
retourner c'est dur est un essai c'est
compliqué je suis pas sûr là que ces
carreaux kahn de faire autant de deux
trous ce soit bien ce que là tu perds
tellement de temps pour développer ton
al-dam fait tellement de trous pénible
vraiment essayer d'avoir un minimum de
trous en 3d mais je fais ce que je peux
un jeu fêtera tout en un
en réalité ça me dérange pas un coup
comme ça arrange faire [ __ ]
4 ce que l'ag géant qu'un cavalier de
plus à poser que lui et je lui as déjà
de poser en ces sept quoi donc j'ai
l'impression s'il doit faire pioncer 7
si j'aurais c'est moi qui ai le matos à
poser mais la ssn et prend 1,8
du coup non seulement tu fais un échec
et en plus tu gagnes une tour
mais tu regagne un tempo sur la dame tu
as fait hyper malleray donc là c'est une
nouvelle victoire mais j'ai du mal à
remonter
j'ai toujours à huit points
allez je vais jouer rapidement j'ai fait
rage 6 pour essayer de reprendre 2 2 et
ça je sais que c'est bien une bonne
structure à ce jeu mais moi peut-être
faire pareil que moi fallait que je
mette encore un pion j'ai ici sécheurs
est cool
laisser manger ça me rassure gagne un
thème pour mais là il s'est pas mal
développé que je vais prendre et une
développés vont vraiment il n'ya pas
trop de pièces manger j'ai peut-être
d'une tour en 1 8 un foin f8 un fourrage
7 touch d'un fou ici pour henri taquet
et prend des 5 intéressant chance à rien
une dame vos quatre points 1,5 vers des
pièces 1,3435 2.35 c'est quoi c'est fou
c'est le cavalier ok le fou est plus
fort que le car al
j'ai quand même envie de prendre son
cabas loi je vais poser ici sur échec et
le truc c'est que s'ils posent le fou je
vais prendre je reposerai le fou et je
vais réussir est ménagé car réussir à
rentrer un petit peu
ok
ok je vais faire que j'ai déjà cavaliers
des deux qui est pas mal non je perds
pied 10
je voulais faire mieux mais je gagne la
dame quand même je pensais peut-être
avoir mieux mais non
ok
maintenant je vais passer par derrière
je vais passer par là parce que du coup
quand tu y mets un truc pour couvrir je
fais cavaillé g3 et dames pranger 2 et 6
montrer la lingerie qui aura lieu 3 et
la dame j'utilise angers 2 ok ça gagne
ok je suis en train de remonter sur pas
mal je veux qu'il réussisse quoi qu'il
en soit ouais je prononcer car en
réalité ce gambie dame il devra pas
vraiment fonctionné je vais posant des
trois noms pour garder mon pions bref je
pose en d3 peut-être eux-mêmes prend 2,4
et posez-la là bas parce que la gambie
dame
il souffre un peu quoi mettre le
fourguer 4 comme ça je vais peut-être
prend des poses en c2 peut-être que vous
prend des 3 es le meilleur coup ici hein
voilà je prends je lui met un échec
sept sacs fils de dames et meilleur coût
attends je prends la sueur échec et à et
je vais prendre la tour va être tout qui
tombe pour perceval et karadoc
bah c'est complètement finir déjà le
front des sages de la pas encore une
pièce il posa un truc qui ne fait même
pas mal du tout je faire un échec qui
doit sacrifier la dame
sinon je prends ces trois et je reprends
je prendrais saddam du lion vous
renforcer la pression au caire échec et
mat
ok gagner toujours du mal à recoller
mais ça gagne triche est dans ta face à
les plus dangereux peut-être je vais
jouer cette variante là je vais essayer
cette variante là qui me semblait semi
théorique
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya pas mal de
gens qui jouaient ça comme ça et qu'il
pose le pion 4 après dans un deuxième
temps je vais prendre la sage regrette
un pion ça va en fait le pion m6 ils
empêchent de se faire poser la gueule
ok ça c'est bien joué à ce que ses
intérêts sans trembler net en cavale il
assuré cheikh
je sais parfaitement
ce que c'est too much ou pas j'ai des
lions aps qui menace sa sur échec quand
même que je peux faire un échec lacie
vient là je pose en g2 je pose en f3 et
je mets la dame
ouais non je pense pas qu'il ait d'attac
de maths si c'est lui qui fait les
échecs mais attends c'est pas sûr il
recule ici ok attend c'est pas si simple
c'est pas simple du tout j'arrive pas
posée n'at il pas posé comme je le
voudrais
ça me fait chier de donner ça
le faire un coup bizarre j'ai juste
faire ça je me blinde un peu et je
menaces poupées 4 je pense pas qu'ils
puissent mater et du coup ci prend à
chaque fois je lui fais chaque et s'ils
commencent à poser un pion j'aurai le
temps de faire de pause et angers 2 en
fait et je me prends plus l'écart à
l'épreuve cet échec dans les variantes
pions j'ai 2 h droits et options getma
et psion g2g j'ai le temps de me faire
couper 4
bon c'est chaud mais là c'est chaud pour
lui aussi de trouver un bon coup il a
beaucoup de choix
sais tu pas faire juste croire je suis
tu as roi je suis dit la dame g8 et
immature obligé de le manger
ok maintenant je suis obligé de le
manger
ok il fait ça je vais poser un pion g6
ce que tu veux faire d'alger 7,3 prend
cavailles âge 5,3 suite posé g73 g8 mais
il a plu et quand il prend la tour je
fais fou prends et je fais un contre
échec
donc il n'a pas le temps de me matter en
prenant g8 repose en g7 et c'est ok il
me laisse jouer
il me laisse jouer
je vais faire flamber quatre échecs roi
des indes damencourt prend un tour prend
matt donc il part de l'autre côté je
vais faire pions j'ai deux échecs s'y
prendre la touche pause dame rassure
maths il doit faire roi prend je vais
pas maté
qu'ai je fait cavalier h quatre échecs
mais je vois pas de bahts c'est moi qui
vais me faire mater au final c'est moi
qui sais j'ai pas à cette pièce pour
mater je me suis raté les gars [ __ ]
fallait sûrement que je que je pose en
vain sur échec et que j'avais un match
c'est sûr j'avais un match c'est sûr
damages 2 kg 3e marche pas je pose en g7
veut faire mater c'est évident qu'il y
avait qu ariane 5 pour faire maths il
l'a raté mais là c'est sûr je me fais ma
tête j'ai parce que j'ai raté
alors qu'est ce que j'ai raté
c'est évident que j'ai raté un truc à
aimer plus les pièces que j'avais à
poser mais là si je me rappelle j'avais
une tâche vous êtes reposé tam il prend
je prends il vient là je pose
il prend et là j'avais un mal c'est sûr
je posais un cavalier et je mate avec la
tour os ça qu'il fallait faire c'est ça
que j'ai raté
pas facile a comme je préviens je suis
pas très très fort à ça
des dommages de relâchement je finir 2e
je pense ce qui sera par al au caire jeu
développé ou alors il reste 10 minutes
oulala je me fais attaquer de partout ça
je suis plus concentré
c'est malheureux
mais faire ça et ça je vais reprendre du
pillon il avait peut-être fou prime si
ce qui était fort je reprends du fou
pardon ok je pas si mal je pense parce
que j'ai beaucoup de matériel et à ok ça
je vais prendre 2 e charles sont d'être
bien couverts caisse assez chiant et je
vais remettre la tour en huit comme ça
quand il prend je reprends je fais un
échec comme sacha un échec et je garde
des pièces bien proche de mon roi ok
maintenant je vais faire flamber 4g tous
développés mais je suis capable de poser
énormément de choses
je vais commencer par poser un lion à
[Musique]
quel jeu posé un cavale pour couvrir ce
qui est peut-être sacrifier la dame
ouais c'est chiant je suis foutu j'ai
oublié cette idée là bas je suis
vraiment mauvais je suis vraiment pas
très fort ce fairway f7
les pauses je suis trop laissé fait
exposer mon roi dame ici je faire dame
roi de 8,3 ici du coup sûr qu'il a un
match
c'est sûr qu'il ya un math c'est évident
qu'il ya un math
ouais ça j'ai vu questerre carey price
is le mat pions prend et pour poser un
pion et ferb en 17 matchs et l'allemagne
quelle profession prend pions f7 et
dames 17 matchs et sur roya fuite en
effet tour ici d'avoir ont de façon
posée je suis obligé en fait je suis pas
arrivé je pense dans les combinaisons
tactiques de fin mais je suis trop
mauvais en stratégie ok
bon il a posé beaucoup de choses
je mangeais 6
si je réussis je pense qu'il avait un
matin bon c'est réussit pas à mater ça
va bien se passer un ok je te prends
voilà de moins en moins de pièces à
poser je vais faire plus on prend g5
tempo parce que je pense qu'il va poser
salle forcera à jouer vite
elle a il est en sueur ok mon à moi de
jouer
déjà je faire un échec
je vais faire un échec là
ok à
je prends un peu de matos une nouvelle
fois son roi est bien protégé j'ai du
mal à mater c'est compliqué comme j'ai
faim
je vois
pas de mal pour lui je vais laisser
jouer ce qu'un fait rage et vu mais je
prends du canal il n'y a pas d'échec si
fait pions et cherche je fais contre
échec
ok maintenant je vais avec une tour ici
du coup j'arrive pas à mater bordel quel
faire fou j'ai 2 je vais être là tout
ranger un est d'alger de maths j'ai eu
du mal c'est sûr qu'il y avait mieux
c'est dur - reste deux minutes par
c'était marrant en tout cas c'est
amusant mais un vrai nom c'est dommage
qu'il fasse pas au lieu d title tueuse
et détournant un peu comme ça un peu
plus fun
c'est ouf comme le jeu est très marrant
à l'aria sune 40
va-t-on réussir à mettre encore des
points
je crois pas vraiment un bon va échanger
oulaya le curage de quito où vivent de
façon il reste 3 10 on n'aura pas le
temps de finir
malheureusement alors ça ok bon ok je
n'aurai pas le temps de mater jeu façon
j'ai pas de maths
façon j'ai pas de made c'est moi qui me
fais attaquer j'ai complètement raté
proche d'eux mais il ya plus de temps
donc on en restera là
elles se rendent seconde ou la caisse
qui me fait il fallait faire échec
si j'avais un carrier se serait maths je
l'attend et ça ça mais bon je suis quand
même j'ai pas assez de matos pour finir
le tap sierrois v8 mais le pion au
cassis champions 17
on sait ce pion des huit dames 17 pouces
et 7 bons à dommage roissy je faisais
foulée cinq matches bon il m'avait donné
la partie toute façon moi j'ai fini
deuxième du coup devant triche derrière
arjen mais devant triche est dans ta fat
et barban ces maquis à mon avis joué
mieux que moi
le premier est trop fort et ben écoute
si si les spécialistes de jeu là on voit
bien il ya des stratégies à voir qu'il
faut connaître et donc faites attention
à votre septième rangée on y re jours à
l'occasion on se retrouve demain du coup
merci les gars ciao ciao